two and a half minutes of opening
credits that do nothing for nobody
DC Comics if you were a Batman fan back
in 1989
you seriously wondered what you got
yourself into when songs written and
performed by prints came up you probably
even like prints but doing songs for a
Batman movie kind of like if you want to
see the Dark Knight and saw a credit
songs written and performed by Kanye
West holy this is a nightmarish City
landscape full of matte paintings
Sanchez Mexican food advertisement that
says only the name in goddamn Gotham no
phone number street address kind of late
1980s cab vert izing is this so this
asshole takes the family's cat and that
guy's an asshole to be certain but then
inexplicably the dad decides we should
walk all across town looking for taxis
even though we're directly in front of a
theater where many taxis will show up
and there's no way that a cab can
somehow use the roads to get us going in
the right direction
I know where we are so let's run into
this creepy alley and look for a cab
animated Batman is not here to stop
robberies just to hurt the bad guys who
do them way after they occur also he
thought that was Bruce Wayne's family
and so did I but nope fake-out just
regular muggers in all of Gotham Bruce
chose to follow and apprehend petty
holdup criminals just because they
attack in an alley like his parents
killers but meanwhile murders out the
ass are taking place all over the city
in non bruce wayne memory alley
territory at man while smart and awesome
kicks the gunless guy first for some
reason I want you to tell all your
friends about me publicity I could have
gotten by preventing the robbery in the
first place and saving the dad from a
nasty hit to the head but now I like
this mysterious word-of-mouth publicity
better Harvey Dent really does later
turn into two-face in the series because
eventually he becomes Tommy Lee Jones
evil people's set meeting with crooked
cop a mere two blocks from recent crime
scene this is Tim Burton's vision of
Gotham a bunch of what the are they
thinking architecture and traffic
consisting mostly of station wagons of
course I have to do is get thrown into a
vat of chemicals for this oddly specific
foreshadowing to come true the save the
festival basket is filled with monopoly
money could you tell me which of these
guys is Bruce Wayne I'm not a very good
reporter so I need all the help I can
get
Alfred who is serving the whole of this
party is also able to follow Bruce's
every step to pick up after him
Commissioner
why in the hell denoxin vicki vale think
the Commissioner Gordon decided to walk
into some dark room full of antiques
after rushing out of the party and why
isn't it locked were you oh sorry
Bruce Wayne seriously wealthy socialite
Bruce Wayne nobody knows what this guy
looks like ah 1989 when a two-way mirror
and an oscillating VHS camera were
considered futuristic technology only
the rich could afford also when you need
video surveillance of a room be sure to
have at least three cameras all shooting
it basically the same angle all right
what's up anonymous - amazing the sound
quality these cameras which must be 50
feet away can isolate a conversation in
the middle of a huge party shoot to kill
know what I mean actually now that you
say you know what I mean after something
as simple as shoot to kill
I wonder if you mean something else
entirely these bad guys doing bad guy
things are super clueless about stealth
entry's look at this gung-ho cop who
plays by his own rules at Ten bad guys
who don't give about killing me at the
drop of a hat I got this covered does
Jack have any idea what this does or is
he just hoping against hope that these
levers will somehow aid in his escape
Batman could easily start punching jack
and tying him up for the cops right now
what decides to wait until the situation
is way more dangerous before doing
Batman stuff this cap took creepin
lessons from the assholes in the smooth
criminal video this is guy I don't know
Batman makes a secret getaway even
though everyone can see him through the
smoke
check the roof guys for no reason we can
figure out Jack doesn't simply drown
after being thrown into the toxic
chemical sludge one half the Wayne gate
has metal leaves all over the other side
does not and I'm much more concerned
about this than I am any of the plot
going on right now how's the soup excuse
me makes for a nice joke but damn why
did they decide to eat dinner at
opposite ends of the table on a first
date is Bruce that goddamn formal dining
room is definitely not you I like how
much he knows him after one date haha
illegal surgery clinic has sign flashing
surgery which I guess helps attract
customers without also attracting cops
wait is his bathroom inside a vault of
some kind amazing how the lighting in
this place agrees with setting up a
dramatic reveal Bruce Wayne had sex with
Vicki Vale and instead the movie showed
me the chemical warehouse assault
because the movie hates me and also is
probably aiming for a pg-13 rating why
would you do this your bedroom where
you've just been at a civilian
Jesus you live in a mansion find a
different room for this you have to do
it overnight
lately get a load of me kind of amazing
after Heath Ledger's great performance
we just forgot how great Jack Nicholson
was in this movie though we will remove
us in here what if we say no
nobody wants a war bad guy challenge was
another bad guy at a meeting and falls
for the no hard feelings ruse cliche
which anyone who's seen a Bond film
knows to never fall for yes sir
the compliance with this mission
requires me to put on my sunglasses I
just want you to do your job I'll be it
with glasses two times too big for my
face but I'm doing my job
there's this guy who cares top
photojournalist in Gotham has zero
interest in the identity of the city's
infamous vigilante stalking also Wayne
Manor which goes through the trouble of
having three cameras trained on the
Japanese Arsenal room has no video
security around the premises just in
case someone starts snooping around the
house in this debris-filled alley Bruce
Wayne rich early adds to the garbage by
laying flowers at the spot of his
parents death also he plays his roses on
the side of his parents murders rather
than simply visiting their graves I mean
you're honoring the place they got
murdered what the unauthorised dead
parents rose examination time to pay the
check
Joker gets away with this in front of
all these people at least five cops on
the top of the steps because reasons
Bruce gets shot in the shoulder but he's
Batman so it didn't hurt I guess did the
Joker build this contraption for the
express purpose of punching a TV when he
doesn't like something it appears to
have zero use outside of destroying a TV
but I thought it asked
I feel that there's a certain weight
that lifts when she is here she was here
one time when she did so you're dealing
with a small sample size Alfred find out
what's so special about the alley at
Pearl and Phillips Street Jesus is like
fatal attraction or something she
doesn't have a hunch that Bruce is
Batman she's obsessed with the rich guy
who showed her a nice time one night she
will not be ignored Bruce stop the press
who is that that's Vicki Vale Alice's
movies Joker ultimately motivated by his
penis does that sound like any version
of the Joker you've ever heard of he
wants to cause chaos and kill Batman
that's it
I'm not even sure he has a dick how does
Joker override the broadcast at a news
station what equipment have we seen that
allows him to do this only 13 deaths he
shipped more than a million cases of
that movie strongly suggests these news
anchors are going makeup-free to avoid
Joker contamination but then why does
this asshole anchor have to mega sores
on his face that even makeup couldn't
hide did he bury his face on a box of
herpes
how did makeup even hide that mountain
in the first place I'm sorry but I'm
gonna be 10 minutes late to the museum
okay does vicki vale do besides stock
Bruce Wayne that is gonna make her 10
minutes late luckily though it happened
and now Bruce knows she's at the Museum
under suspicious circumstances even
Gotham's aren't using him can't escape
looking like some of its Wall
were built with leftover submarine parts
which is good because these giant vents
will make spreading Joker's poison so
easy Vicki Vale is so made up with so
many products on her person I wonder how
she avoided diet surely she's heard of
the massive makeup scare going on right
now here's one massive Prince music
video without Prince a minute and a half
of art destruction I'm supposed to find
humor in soup or discount banks I kind
of like this but I won't tell any of my
other henchmen not to deface it and
expect them to simply get the message no
matter where they are in this museum
she's a living work of art oh she's
still hot brightening Batman's entrance
somehow it doesn't kill both the Joker
and Vicki via falling shards of glass
also I'd like to know my climbing to the
museum roof and smashing through the
window was a better option than simply
busting through the doors vicki could be
in all sorts of trouble but you decide
better get the longer more complicated
dangerous and dramatically inside also
luckily for her and the plot of this
movie
Vicki somehow has the wherewithal to
grab her camera bag put it around her
shoulder even though she has no clue
what's going on and I'm pretty sure it
was hanging on a chair and that would
have been way too hard to grab from here
but thank god she did right the
Batmobile makes one slightly tight turn
and a Blues Brothers car accident breaks
out also movie answers the question how
many assholes will blindly drive into
each other even though they had plenty
of chances to stop the answer is 16 how
do these dumb assholes have any idea
where Batman way and how did they get
around the bulldozer the stop traffic
and all the etc going on how much do you
weigh 108 I think come on she's
beautiful but 108 hahahaha see the thing
I'm above grabbing whatever you do don't
let go
Batman gives these instructions a split
second before Vicki can't even process
it and could have killed her also he can
jump down to beat up these dudes he
doesn't need to beat up for any reason
just go the camera is a machine and God
came from the machine to preserve
Batman's identity
I see the Indiana Jones is strong with
this one
stop if this Batmobile only stops when
Batman tells it to then how did it not
run into a hundred cars on the way here
and possibly drill a few pedestrians on
the way also how did it lose the cops
that immediately started following the
Batmobile once he remotely activated it
the only way to get to Wayne Manor is
through Tim Burton's woods all these
bats indicate roaming free and Batman
decided to cage one of them because he's
a heartless bastard they're great
survivors including in this cage where I
make Alfred come down and feed him every
day with nutritious gruel hairspray
won't do it along but hairspray mixed
with lipstick and perfume will be toxic
except to Vicky Vale who is probably
wearing all those things plus makeup
dependence press there's no reason why
Batman even took her to his lair all he
had to do was take her to her apartment
knock her out take the film she shot and
once back home send the envelope to the
press or put it on her nightstand but I
guess it's way more dramatic to drive
her all the way out here which is how
Batman likes it I guess also why didn't
he just make copies of all this stuff
and put this package in the trunk of the
Batmobile before he went to go save
Vicky why did you bring me here you
could have seen that stuff to the press
yourself Vicky Vale would be amazing at
cinema since why does Batman have what
appears to be two bottles of mouthwash
down here in the Batcave computer
station the grown woman with the teddy
bear on her bed definitely deserves a
sit by the way Batman totally walked
into an apartment building dragging an
unconscious woman into it and no one saw
him ah this is what she says as opposed
to he put his hand inside my bra without
permission this time all these people
behind him they're the founders of
shutterstock no lie oh my god this story
is happening during the harry s truman
years I had lots of modern equipment
during that age also aside from the
ridiculous proofreading errors on this
page and the total non article
underneath the headline these
combinations are not what Batman told
Vicky earlier it was any combination
that caused death and he specifically
said hair spray mix with lipstick and
perfume also these are some extremely
specific combinations and I don't know
how Joker planned to do the harm he
expected to do these were the only
combinations I have given a name to my
pain and it's weird specific chemical
reactions that only killed 13 total
people you can't really blame Batman for
this can you plus after you told the
entire city about the new and improved
Joker products everyone was afraid to
use anything anyway what a dumb plan
this is
the Joker is addictive perfectly good
television sets dick avails room is
number nine but if you're wondering
where rooms 43 through 87 are there to
the right
oh no Joker's here right at the time
Bruce Wayne is here hey how come vicki
has a large bowl of popcorn on her
mantle and Vicki is now in this super
tense moment casually eating the stale
popcorn she grabbed off the mantle for
defense ever dance with the devil in the
pale mind what I always asked that of
all my prey never once does Joker say
this until he says it to Bruce Wayne
giving him the clue that Jack killed his
parents
he didn't tell Eckhart gristle or that
crime lord dude this phrase before
killing them so nice strike oh that's
not true at all Joker runs and stands
over Bruce to taunt him but somehow
completely misses the total lack of
blood from Bruce's Back to the Future
three bulletproof vests also he doesn't
shoot him a few more times to make sure
he's dead his children leave Vicki's
place just because he fired a bullet and
he's worried about cops showing up I
didn't even bother to come here if the
reason wasn't to either kill or kidnap
her luckily this tree is bulletproof and
the Joker didn't aim her head or dick
why even bother opening this present
that could have been more poison the
Gotham newspaper office cheers for the
New York Giants Gotham City painting
Joker here I love how the mayor dude is
looking directly to his left helping the
audience know he's reacting to Joker but
this only makes sense if somehow the
field team set up a live feed television
monitor of the station's broadcast
directly to the mayor dudes left which
come on they did not do but one thing I
am NOT it's a killer why would you make
this claim if you're the Joker the
entire press saw you stabbed a guy on
the steps of City Hall and you were
implicated in killing 13 two people with
poison I'm sure Dominic Toretto would
vouch for you though we are not prepared
to discuss any deals does Joker know the
exact configuration of these particular
monitors at the TV station to make a
swiping motion that will clear them off
and what exactly does that even do mayor
wasn't even being broadcast anyway you
heard it folks
20 million and you saw it folks my hands
went from one position to a drastically
different one in the next shot eating
popcorn with gloves on you're not only
ruining the fine leather gloves with
salt and butter and other chemicals
you're also putting whatever bullet is
on your gloves into your mouth the
Wayne's enjoyed that place so much they
decided to walk down deserted alleys and
streets afterwards laughing like asshole
by the pale moon
add the Wayne parents to the large group
of people to whom Jack Napier did not
ask this question before killing them no
hesitation whatsoever in killing the
parents but poses the kid a question
that makes no sense and then he doesn't
even kill him also this movie makes a
massive change to Batman lore by having
Joker be his parents killer okay fine
but then why would a psycho like Joker
kill the parents but leave a little kid
witness alive he wouldn't do that
right this Batman shouldn't exist Alfred
makes the all-time biggest presumption
in the world and leads Vicki into the
secret Batcave but that wasn't just
another night for either of us was it I
mean we both got to each other didn't
you got a meal and had sex there was
nothing much special about it
none of these henchmen fall down from
being struck by these dozens of
ricocheting bullets with everyone
knowing what chemicals not to mix on the
fact that it only killed 13 people one
day was there a pressing need to destroy
the axis chemicals factory in this
manner he could have done it way more
stealthily and with less danger to
himself right in a minute we're about to
see the bat way which could easily have
flown over to do this job in the air
Rolo quit oh is that why they got the
title for Birdman sneaky you want to
send something so I will for virtually
no reason at all we too many minutes of
this goofy ass parade and I'm a prince
fan it's actually beyond ridiculous
after all the things Joker's done that
nobody in the police force wants to
arrest him right now by the way law
enforcement just totally disappeared in
this movie didn't they take the pictures
Gotham's greed whoa there pal it's
probably a guy with a pretty good union
job who's supposed to think of the
headlines you just report dickhead
this looks cool I guess but thank God
the Joker's poison gas was light as
helium am i right our surgical masks
really going to prevent you from
breathing in all this gas and since when
does being in a car protect you from gas
that can make its way into any of the
thousands of openings cars have that
wing is equipped with a special cutter
thing to grab balloons just in case that
comes up during his assault on the Joker
Batman decides to give an unseen
audience a glimpse of the batwing
silhouetted against the moon that's good
marketing right there
Batman the Batman with a targeting
computer and everything this is the
Joker with missiles and bullets and
Joker seems to even know he'll miss with
no explanation
and then this comically large gun is
able to shoot down that batwing what
because it's a comically long Roger
Rabbit gun are you kidding me I've got
to get you to the church on time but why
do you really need to climb this super
tall church in order to get a helicopter
ride why not have a car waiting that
worked at City Hall when you killed the
crime lord guy with a pen that man
survives this crash because let me guess
he's Batman this is some Spider Man here
before they made spider-man 3 this was
pretty iconic imagery right makes for
interesting visuals but the height of
this church bell tower is stretching
into Cinderella territory in terms of
believability
how does Joker have any henchman at all
in this church remember he just decided
to walk to this place after his plans
with the gas balloons didn't pan out
Batman came in right behind him and no
one else followed the Joker the whole
way they basically already have to be
here sitting and waiting in a church
that Joker had no idea he was going to
enter for any reason also why is Batman
so far away from them after this shot of
him getting out of the batplane how many
times does Kim Basinger scream in this
movie how many times did they possibly
call her back put her into studio demand
different screams and the ADR process
and threatened to shoot orphans if she
didn't give him the right one where is
this henchman been the whole time if
he's able to beat that ass this easily
why didn't he show up before now also
out of any of these church goons even
come close to hanging with Batman in a
fight we thought the hero fell to his
death only to find he's holding on to
something impossible and surprises
everyone cliche well Batman doesn't kill
people but yeah he totally just did
Joker Falls for this do you I'd objected
that statement wildly if this movie
hadn't just shown us Batman killing
someone so I give up the second time
this happens in the movie and it makes
zero sense
where could Joker be the Batman couldn't
see this coming Batman shoots this thing
land with expert movie magic it's
somehow wraps around the Joker's foot
well also anchoring itself to the
gargoyle how does it work you that's how
well it all worked out but one question
once he and Vicky get back up to the
roof and they walk back down the steps
many of which were destroyed how do they
get around that huge Bell Joker cut down
to block the entrance and once they get
past that how are there not millions of
cops and press waiting for them when
they get down nearly every scene of this
movie in downtown Gotham occurs near the
monarch theater Gotham's supposed to be
like huge as New York City but almost
every scene takes place near here making
Gotham feel like Hill Valley to cast a
shadow on the heart of the city call how
do we call Knox always thinks of the
questions other reporters are too afraid
to ask he gave us a signal which he can
see anywhere from his mansion miles away
from the city or unblock by tall
buildings when he's in an alley
somewhere
ever rub another man's
so this only to point out and make
public the dishonesty the downright
villainy of boss Jim W Kenny's political
machine all right here's how we begin
first task reconnaissance know
everything that's going on in all three
casinos from the rotation of the dealers
to the path of every cash card
Beetlejuice Beetlejuice beetlejuice it's
on your mind often leaving to make you
understand you're not Batman anymore you
have to find another way you can't
handle the truth
let's
now that's real acid so I want to see
Google people real acid I know why
you're afraid to go out at night the
Batman how did we end up here this place
is horrible smells like balls there are
two rules to remember if you want to
have a good time rule number one never
run out of coal 45 will number two never
forget rule number one you're at
cinemasins we watch a lot of movies a
lot of bad movies unfortunately the sad
reality is this almond leaves our
capacity for looking at anything else
impaired
fortunately with audible we can
entertain ourselves without the use of
our eyes see with audible all you need
is your ears and with their library of
over 180,000 audio books you'll never
run out of great stuff to put into them
they even have apps for the ios and
android so you can listen from anywhere
i have to do to get started is go to
audible.com slash cinemasins to get a
free audiobook and 30-day trial
subscription